comment est-ce que vous réagissez à ce
positionnement très mal c'est à dire
très mal le bon docteur castaner donne
des certificats des diagnostics aux uns
aux autres mais si en marche a envie
d'exister son plan territorial mais
qu'ils se comptent qu'ils se présentent
sur leur éthique vire
voilà c'est ça c'est bien je suis
toujours en train de chercher là la
colonne vertébrale idéologique dans
marche ni droite ni gauche bien c'est
pas une colonne vertébrale idéologique
il y a des gîtes des maires de droite
cas des maires de gauche dans ce pays il
ya des mères aussi non inscrits dans et
dans les petites communes mais là
manifestement ce qui est intéressant
marché des grandes villes grandes les
grandes villes mais messi en marché un
projet politique municipale ben voilà
qu'il se présente qu'ils se comptent moi
je aucun aucun problème mais cette idée
de donner des bons points des mauvais
points
je te ferai roi je te ferai plus rien tu
es mon sujet fasse qu une suffisance une
arrogance moi qui qui m'exaspère qui
correspond aussi un peu ce qui se passe
au niveau national c'est les
sénatoriales ont été un bon signe en la
matière monsieur patriat espérait soit
110 80 il menace même d'un scrutin non
plus pour c'est pas même mode de scrutin
mais les sénateurs en marche sont moins
nombreux depuis la dernière élection
c'est à dire que les grands électeurs
n'ont pas choisi en marche si monsieur
castetner exister territorialement en
tant que chef de parti c'est pas le
ministre que j'interpelle c'est le chef
de parti et bien qu'il aille jusqu'au
bout qu'ils présentent des listes en
marche et c'est vrai que dans une
municipale une liste d'une alchimie
il y a de tout dans une liste et nous
verrons bien ce qui est le plus apprécié
par les électeurs ou plan d'accord au
local vous refusé sa main tendue est ce
que vous
imaginez donc pas passer des accords
effectivement avec la république en
marche que par ailleurs vous combattez
aux niveaux nationaux mais encore une
fois c'est l'expression d'alchimie il
peut y avoir sur un projet politique
locale des alliances politiques par
exemple pour éviter que le front
national met la main sur une ville
tout ceci est possible mais dans la
clarté et là j'ai l'impression que
monsieur castetner est plutôt dans la
dans la tuyauterie dans l'échafaudage de
d'accords locaux
je veux dire à la discrétion des uns et
des autres vous avez peur que certains
de vos camarades socialistes disent
banco 1 c'est de sauver leur tête en
tout un lien avec la république en
marche en tout cas c'est de l'ancien
monde tout ça c'est une très très très
ancien monde
ces petits type d'accord que cherche
monsieur castaner